[Musique]
voici arcade des french wings
personnalités célèbres du breakdance
français il était membre du jury de la
battle breaking breakdance et toi en
2024 qui avait lieu samedi 29 janvier
aux mureaux 1-2 compte deux versions
bonnie and clyde l'idée c'est de pouvoir
faire des couples en mixte parce que
voilà c'est un sport où justement il ya
une parité il ya des big girl et debbie
boys et les deux ont du talent et marié
les deux sur sur une battle ça nous
paraissait très intéressant quatre
couples mixtes sont donc affrontés
objectif valoriser la culture du break
mais sanaa fidèles vice championne de
france elle a commencé ce sport à 5 ans
a pas vraiment de règles c'est tu
t'amuses tu vas chercher l'adversaire et
voilà comme miles and certain bieber
baby girl se prépare en vue des jo de
paris en 2024 nouvelles disciplines
inscrites pour ces jeux un rêve pour ce
duo fraternel et jeu direct accroché et
après par la suite je me suis appliqué
est de plus en plus en faisant des
compétitions des shows et c est ma
petite soeur m'a suivi ensuite vers
l'âge de 9 10 ans et ensuite bien vite
et est doux et donc la vie de prix un
bon niveau et on a vite fait des
compétiteurs ensemble du coût et des
conditions comme ça on en fait souvent
ensemble cointet l'objectif pour tout le
monde je pense
et
on aimerait tous se représenter leur
france audio
terre de breakdance la ville des mureaux
labellisé terre de jeux 2024 accueillera
lors d'un stage l'équipe de france en
février prochain